I wanted to make a very quick video just
to simply say or explain why the hell am
I actually doing this and because my my
perception of social media 1224 months
ago what was an exit one definitely and
the way I view it now is that social
media is a tool where you can reach so
many more people and you can reach so
many more people with a good message or
if you want to share negative negativity
which there's so much of that in today's
world then then great and that's what
you can use it for but for me the fact
that I can share something from what
I've learnt in my life or whatever it is
hopefully a positive thing and people
have seen that is that if it can help
one purchase one person that just makes
me so so happy and to receive messages
saying that oh you made me think of this
or you've inspired me to do that that
just makes me so happy and I absolutely
love that so that's why I'm doing this
the fact that I could potentially help
one person just makes me so happy